let's get more on this from DW ethics
correspondent Martin GAC welcome Martin
we just heard the bishop they're saying
mistakes were made but this does not
sound like a mistake if you believe
what's in this report this was a system
this was the system that this doesn't
cut it anymore the church is not
entitled to talk about mistakes at all
one of the things that the grand jury
sort of brings forth is that essentially
the church at least in the state of
Pennsylvania and within the diocese
particular Pittsburgh which is one third
of where those people charged are from
was essentially operating as a criminal
organization and this is actually a very
damning charge so that is to say there
was a system for both protecting these
people that evidently was perpetuating
the problem so you know I think that
apologies is something that well just
quite simply has no place in this
conversation anymore and we heard
briefly in the report only two charges
against more than 300 abuses and their
names are known so why not more charges
well this charge is some of these
charges go back so many years so I mean
I think that and there's a statute of
limitation there is a statute of
limitations and there are only 300 cases
in this case that had been put on the
table but I mean presumably we're gonna
see a lot more and presumably we're
going to hear about it a lot more
victims now the issue is that because of
the policy of secrecy that the church
officially adopted actually the the the
previous Pope Benedict has essentially
said that anybody that would be that
could be caught turning turning
information to national authorities or
legal authorities would be actually
excommunicated because of this kind of
policy it made it almost impossible to
actually track perpetrators through this
means that you know the possibilities of
bringing charges were actually quite
reduced so this is a report from a grand
jury released by the States Supreme
Court what happens next
well I mean this is a state prosecutor
and this will actually be moved
per I mean charges will be brought but
what is interesting at this point is
that this is happening in several places
around the world so Australia's now you
notice charges as putting on trial card
bell but more interestingly perhaps over
the last two days a prosecutor in Chile
who is investigating abuse cases has
requested from the Vatican that they
turn documents to the prosecution I
think that this essentially the endgame
is whether the church from the very very
top that is to say from the Vatican will
actually start turning documents and
evidence to national authorities that
can prosecute cases keep in mind that
it's very likely that these cases are
still going on so this has not come to
an end these policies are essentially
still in place
so you mentioned then that from the top
there was that this this policy of not
turning over documents to state
authorities if criminal cases are being
brought around the world can the
Catholic Church be forced to hand these
documents over it depends were and in
many cases no or the answer is simply no
because there are many many situations
many legal contexts and and frameworks
in which for instance confession is
actually protected so we Fabrice goes to
say his bishop and confesses that he has
molested a child that is actually
protected the other problem is that the
church itself has actually developed a
policy as I was saying of not disclosing
these things to national authorities so
it would have to change the policy
within the church and we're talking
about a massive organization in which
they actually begin to say yes we're
turning these things to national order
authorities this would have to come from
this Pope we'll leave it there fella
Martin yeah thank you my pleasure